as it was foretold
aim on the dark God lives again if any
hope remains for our galaxy it lies my
only one piece of the prophecy remains
unfulfilled that on the world where a
Mon was reborn the last light will be
revealed there is one me
I'll creature
no NASA mierda
to the Terrans as the room in the system
hides a long forgot
I must hold his secrets still rest
within its walls there at all it is a
great honor I am praytor talus and I
humbly request your aid an unknown force
has been abducting Templar from our
colony worlds my forces and I have
managed to track them to a Terran
facility but we are under attack by the
swarm swarm I'm on my way Dallas Mayor
dune hide you until I arrive our
brethren are being held prisoner across
the complex we must free them before the
swarm overwhelms the facility is there a
tool I thought I sensed your presence
let's not mince words why are you here
this place holds information I seek
captured brethren I intend to free them
both from the Terrans this facility is a
breeding ground for a Mons hybrid army
my swarm will embrace it for existence
but I never stopped
so let me make this clear stay out of
our ways there a tool
not fear we will not abandon this fight
telus if we are Swift in clever
the swarm
very well I have made our nexus point
ready for your arrival the captive
Templar Arquette's just ahead ready your
blades warriors ruler Siddharth is the
void Kerrigan will send the sworn to
destroy the station's reactor we must
free our brothers before that happens
dark planets we will need to cross the
swarms attack route to reach the
captives move forward only when it is
clear avoid deserts forces at all costs
my skills is i am the heart of darkness
for our tennis least I am the force
swarm gathers for an attack warriors
stay clear of the Serbs have play the
Protoss their flesh will serve the
master minions push forward slay these
hybrid thralls to the last these Terrans
mines have been consumed they are slaves
to the hybrid
here is the void Europe
newsroom
you have not enough moons I like I
I am the whole you have not enough
mineral I like for you have not enough
you must construct additional pylons
eliminate the Protoss base glory to our
master
five hours it was good
are gathering they will surely attack
soon eliminate the central reactor Lulla
sidari you require my skills not enough
energy I am the heart
he shall be as you say
I'm here shadows are a complete I am the
voice
I said command me we are the blades of
life I intriguing it shall be as you say
very well
we move unseen command
you must place that in a power field or
she saw my life for hire you require my
skin we stand as one I am the voice
thank you we believed the end was at
hand what do you know of this facilities
at the Terrans tortured us experimented
upon our flesh most did not survive I
have seen foul work of this nature
before but Neruda's dead whose hand
brought you here alas I know not Gretel
we wish to join you to avenge our
brothers in arms then ready yourselves
Templar
warriors there is another cell ahead go
forth and claim the Vengeance you seek
we are one state by bidding God is the
void for the reckoning I am the voice
the olives
taryn's are walking in impossible they
are experimenting with pylon technology
we should eliminate these Terrans and
reclaim the pile on door
selves
Thunder attack
energy reclaiming the pylon now it is
hard to believe such primitive beasts
can if you let our technology
those we are one with the shadows very
well
you must construct additional pylons he
shall
you require my skills there are cool t3
you must construct additional pylons
move on feat
well done destroying the bridge control
has extended a walkway to our nexus
point
the Serb forces will move soon we must
be cautious
tear apart their reactor the Queen of
Blades demands it you require I'm here
shadows
your time is running short zeera tool
kerrigan you know as well as I the Iman
lives slaying is hybrid is a meaningless
Act we must awaken the Xel'Naga no
response huh there's a reason the stone
the Zerg the final sell awaits us turtle
we should delay no longer
shrieking we move uncie you're a cruel
cold it is the void
now intriguing Oh back to the shadows
another wave of Sir gathers avoid them
if you can heart of darkness he shall be
the sward is upon you Mobius core we are
a tide of death that does not break
just like me I my life
minerals we are one we move the see why
you shall be as you say there are cool
you have not enough minerals very well I
like 4i
we are one with the shadows I am oh cool
you require my skills
we are one you have not enough minerals
you would have not enough minerals state
by bidding
very wise we move unseen Naraku I serve
who now
city to the shadows
is the void steeped I pity
both islands have been returned to our
rifle control warping in reinforcements
now or she saw I'm here shadows I'm here
his shadows
intriguing I am the heart of darkness I
am the voice iliac cold is the not
enough energy defenses are growing
stronger push forward with all I might
the hybrid are free strike them down
assault Mobius course final defenses we
must travel swiftly
those who side with a mom's hybrid
deserve no mercy devour them whole Thank
You brothers but albariño been abducting
Templar ringing up to Terrence stations
turning us into hybrid tell Doreen loves
heretics have never ventured so close to
our worlds this can only be the work of
a Mon Templar where were they holding
you is a larger temple unlike any I have
seen it was called heiress but its
location was kept a secret from us
Mobius and the towel Doreen both
Thunder nerves command he would have no
the location of this to the Atreus
system this is where a Mon was reborn
deep within the saber quadrants and
under tower we
you have aided me in my
I am honorbound to help you ignores we
shall help you clear
you